[Music]
the first work of art as immediate is
abstract and individual as for itself it
has to move away from this immediate
and objective mode towards
self-consciousness
while self-consciousness on the other
hand in the cult
aims at getting rid of the distinction
by which it distinguishes
itself at first from its spirit and by
doing so to produce a work of art which
is
in its own self animate
paragraph 705 is a very
short introductory lead-in
to this new subsection the abstract work
of art
which figures into this second
subsection
of religion religion in the form of
art where we're going to be turning to
look particularly at
greek religion and you notice that
there's some
some references here if you've read
ahead in the text
to what is coming up so for for example
at the very end of this
short paragraph producing a work of art
which is in its own self
animate now the word animate there
could perhaps distract you a little bit
the next section is the living work of
art right
and the german here on im zelps
in itself living or lively
you know here the the term that miller
has chosen
animate it works but it doesn't quite
convey to you that we are talking about
the living work of
art and what is going to be happening in
this section we're moving away from
as we're beginning here the first work
of art which has these
particular characteristics we'll talk
about in just a moment
into something that is
a more adequate vehicle of spirit
and what does that mean to be a vehicle
of spirit something that is going to be
mediating and mediating in complex ways
and mediating for self-consciousness
remember back to the beginning of this
religion section
where hegel brought up these terms
consciousness and self-consciousness and
was saying that you know we're
bringing these together along with
whatever has been achieved in reason
and spirit so there's actually quite a
lot being referenced here
in this short little passage
and we begin at another beginning the
first work of art
as immediate uh mittelbarin right
not just unmediated but immediate
is abstract he says and individual now
individual that's kind of an interesting
thing to say
isn't it given how much stress hegel has
placed on
the individual as the locus of
agency and driving sometimes of evil
as well and this constant
need for reconciling the universal
and the individual why would the
individual
be abstract well that's something we're
going to have to see
worked out in the next few paragraphs
abstract okay that makes perfect sense
right
it is immediate it's abstract it's sort
of like send certainty where we began
in the work itself and where we keep on
beginning over and over again
by now you're probably used to the
hegelian schtick which is
that we begin with something that
appears to be
unmediated right appears to be
abstract appears to be just what it is
being in itself and then we find out we
unpack it and there's much more going on
right
what else is happening here so he tells
us that
as for itself on its side right it has
to move away
from this as he calls it immediate and
objective objective here is gegen
stendlica
existing in the form of an object right
it has to move away
from this immediate and objective mode
towards
self-consciousness what is the it the
work of art
how does the work of art do that through
self-consciousness
and self-consciousness per se
self-consciousness from the beginning of
the self-consciousness section
or the part of the self-consciousness
section that would seem to be
more immediately applicable to this the
unhappy consciousness
no self-consciousness as hegel says
in the cult the cultus and here i think
it's quite important for the
contemporary reader
that we pause for a moment and clarify
the meaning of this word cult
because i think for many people in in
this time
it means something like a very
tight-knit community that is in many
ways heterodox not only to its own
society
but to what we might call more
traditional
or mainstream religion and it has a
tendency to you know deform the
personalities of those who belong to it
often there's like a
beloved leader who turns out to be kind
of a scummy you almost always guy but
sometimes a woman as well
okay put that aside because that is a
contemporary use of the term
but what we mean by cult in religious
studies
or within philosophy particularly in
hegel's time
is the community of worship so
a community of worship could be a cult
in the very late modern
sense but any other community of worship
you know the buddhist sangha
the catholic church you know
the hindu community of vaishnavites all
of those would be examples of
cults in the sense that hegel is using
this term
as would be the communities of worship
centered around
greek temples festivals as we're going
to see a little bit later with their own
literature
so all of that would be part of the cult
as hegel is talking about so
self-consciousness
develops not only within we might say
secular communities or within the family
or
within relations between people but also
within these religious
frameworks and matrices and so he says
self-consciousness in the cult aims at
getting rid of the distinction by which
it distinguishes itself at first from
spirit
right now getting rid of this
distinction
is is a form of overcoming right of
uh auf haven here it's off zoohaven
right
and so it's it's trying to get rid of
this
hard distinction that is separating
itself from
its own spirit and it's going to do
something it's going to take the work of
art the first work of art and transform
it into something
new that's not going to happen right
away
there's going to be a number of steps
and stages but by the end of this
section that's where we're going
producing a work of art which is in its
own self-animate
anime right
so in its in its very nature in its
activity in its agency
it is something that has life that
that exhibits liveliness
that's where we're going in this section
so
hegel's you know sketching the road out
in front of us
the first mode in which the artistic
spirit keeps its shape and its active
consciousness farthest apart is the
immediate mode that is
the shape is there or is immediately
present simply as
a thing in this mode the shape is broken
up into the distinction of individuality
which bears within it the shape of the
self
and of universality which represents the
inorganic essence
in reference to the shape its
environment and habitation
this shape through the raising of the
hole into the pure notion acquires its
pure
spiritually appropriate form it is
neither the crystal the form
characteristic of the understanding
which houses the dead or is illumined by
a soul outside of it
nor is it that blending of the forms of
nature and of thought which
first emerged from the plant thoughts
activity in this being still an
imitation
on the contrary the notion strips off
the traces of root branches
and leaves still adhering to the forms
and
purifies the latter into shapes in which
the crystals straight lines
and flat surfaces are raised into
incommensurable
ratios so that the ensolment of the
organic is taken
up into the abstract form of the
understanding
and at the same time
its essential nature incommensurability
is preserved for the understanding
paragraph 706 is charting out
an important movement that hegel is
narrating for us
that runs through the next paragraph and
you could think of
paragraph 706 and 707
as sort of i suppose the word would be
what diptic
as opposed to triptich when we have
paintings two paintings together
rather than a sequence of three
and you know talking in visual terms
like that
is is quite important because we can see
that
in this early part of this section
the abstract work of art we are talking
about
visual representation hegel is going to
be getting us
beyond that within the framework of the
community of worship or the cult
fairly shortly and this paragraph is
centered almost
entirely on visual representation
tracing out
some of the movements that we saw
earlier
in the religion section in the
introduction and in the
natural religion section as well
so what do we have going on here he says
the first mode in which the artistic
spirit keeps its shape
and its active consciousness farthest
apart
is the immediate mode that is the mode
that we were just talking about at the
beginning
of this section in paragraph 705 right
so artistic spirit spirit in
that's working through art and active
consciousness the self-consciousness
that
is not supposed to be separated from
spirit but which is
uh is in this immediate mode he says the
shape is
there or immediately present simply
as a thing so what are we talking about
in terms of this
shape the object we which we could say
the object of worship or the object
mediating warship the object that allows
us to connect with
the divine that represents it in some
way houses it
is another way of thinking about as
we're going to talk about
in just a moment the vehicle
of the divine for us the religious
worshipers the members of the the
cultists
right and there are going to be two key
aspects to this he says
the the shape the gestalt is broken up
into the distinction
of individuality and universality
individuality he says
bears within it the shape of the self so
we're seeing shape
showing up twice right we've got the
shape
as such and then we've got the shape of
the
self whatself well
the self of the god but it could also be
the self of the
worker and through a process of
identification it could also be
our own self identifying with the self
of the the god and then we have this
side of universality where he says
something quite interesting
it represents the inorganic essence
the inner ganesha vizan
right vasen can mean being it can mean
essence it's something that
is important and this is much more
in the shape of the thing than is
the shape of the self the self as we've
seen in previous paragraphs
negativity inhabits that this is
positivity and
we saw that earlier in the previous
section as well this dialectic between
negativity and positivity right
so the inorganic essence in reference
to the shape so
in reference it related to the shape in
bazook
right uh the of the shape
so which which side is the shape out
well it's on both
you have to have both of these
polarities together
but the universal is in some respects
less driving right it's more important
in a way
i guess because it's universal and it
has the essence
but you know he goes on and he says two
interesting things here so how does it
represent the inorganic essence and
reference of the shape
miller translates these terms as
environment inhabitation habitation
that works i think umvelt would be
another
uh term that we would translate as
environment which we're not seeing here
um its surroundings would be another way
of translating this right its
surroundings its environment
and it's habitation it's the housing
it's setting you know where
where it's being placed now where
is the cult image going that's where we
should think for a bit right
we're not just talking about mere
embellishment around
say a temple or a shrine we're talking
about the thing that's
in the temple or shrine the thing that
centers it
when you would go into an ancient temple
a lot of people don't really realize
this you were very often they were
called the house of the god
and you're entering into a space
that is set apart from the rest of the
environment that you're in and you're
entering a different environment a
different
housing here a different setting as the
worshiper and
in a way you belong less there
than the statue or the image or whatever
it is
of the god does and this goes we could
we could you know do a cross-cultural
analysis
of this it doesn't just have to be greek
temples you could think about
mesopotamian temples you could think
about egyptian temples you could think
about
you know chinese india and we go all
over the place
and look at statuary and artwork and
there's there's you know there's artwork
going into it as well it's very rare
that things are just well there's the
image of the god and then everything
else is just architecture no there's all
sorts of
interesting embellishments we could
carry this forward
even perhaps into thinking about the
medieval cathedrals centered on
the crucifix but with all of this other
stuff
along the way and entering in again into
a sacred
space that provides an environment and a
habitation now hegel
here as i mentioned in paragraph 706
is not going to look at all the possible
forms
that the visual representation could
take here he's really
only talking about two of them
the plant and the crystal and we
encountered these earlier in natural
religion right
so he goes on and he says here we go
this shape through the raising of the
whole into the pure
notion the pure concept acquires its
pure spiritually appropriate form now
does it acquire it in this paragraph
no that's going to happen by the end of
the next paragraph
he says it is neither the crystal the
form characteristic of the
understanding the for stand a human
faculty right
which houses the dead or is illumined by
a soul outside of it we saw that dynamic
play out again
back in natural religion so it's not
that
it's also he says uh not that blending
of the forms of nature
and of thought gadanka which first
emerged from the plant thoughts activity
in this being still an imitation right
an imitation of what of of the floral
vine like you know leaf-like whatever
else it happens to be
uh forms that we're working with which
are
um you know an advance beyond the
crystal we can certainly say
and he says no no what we have here
going on the notion
the concept that's driving this strips
off the traces
of root branches and leaves still
adhering to the forms
and purifies the latter into shapes in
which
the crystals straight lines and flat
surfaces
are raised into incommensurable and he's
using that term there
in commensurability right ratios
connections right so that the ensolment
of the organic
is taken up into the abstract form of
the
understanding and at the same time
its essential nature which is what
incommensurability in commensurate billy
tat
in german is preserved for the
understanding so it's still the
understanding doing the heavy lifting
here
but it's being confronted with something
that is going to
go beyond it and we should pause for a
moment on this word
incommensurability what does that
actually mean
so if you look at it literally right the
come means together with right
uh mensurability is coming from mansura
measure
so things that cannot be in of course
not measured together not measured
by the same measure together that means
they don't
connect up it's sort of like if you ever
had legos
and then you had like off-brand lego
bricks that weren't actually legos
like when i was a kid we had bricks
blocks right which you could buy
cheaply at the store legos were
expensive they were
very much modeled after each other of
course the brix blocks
were a bit cheaper plastic they were
more you know
breakable and they were slightly bigger
than the legos not so much
in length and width but depth
so you couldn't actually get them to
stick together you could either work
with your your brix blocks or you could
work with your legos and they looked
very similar to each other
although the legos came in many colors
bricks blocks only came
in the set that i had in red white and
blue
and so you know you had your legos and
then your your cheap imitation
they were not commensable with each
other we could talk about other kinds of
incommensurability
as well when you try to take
music that's set in a certain
meter and time and transpose it into
another setting
maybe they won't actually fit together
and
when it comes to the life of the mind
and religion and all that
incommensurability may in fact be the
case
quite often it's also the case quite
often for
artistic representation and so this
incommensurability
for the understanding is going to turn
out to be
quite important hegel's not going to
mention it so much but it's there in the
background
what is it that that spirit in the form
of
the understanding at this point cannot
yet assimilate to itself
and which is going to make it grow in
order to be able to
stretch itself into that kind of shape
that's the
the movement ahead of us
but the indwelling god is the black
stone drawn forth from its animal
covering and pervaded with the light of
consciousness the human form strips off
the animal shape with which it was
blended
the animal is for the god merely an
accidental guise
it steps alongside its true shape and no
longer has
any worth on its own account but is
reduced to signifying something else and
has sunk to the level of a mere
symbol by this very fact the shape of
the god
in its own self strips off also the
poverty
of the natural conditions of animal
existence
and hints at the internal dispositions
of animal life
melted into its surface and belonging
only to this surface
the essential being of the god is
however
the unity of the universal existence of
nature
and of self-conscious spirit which in
its actuality confronts the former
at the same time being in the first
instance an
individual shape its existence is one of
the elements of nature
just as its self-conscious actuality is
an individual
national spirit but the former is
in this unity that element reflected
into spirit nature transfigured by
thought and united with self-conscious
life
the form of the gods has therefore its
nature element within it as a
transcendent moment
as a dim memory the chaotic being and
confused strife of the freely existing
elements
the unethical realm of the titans is
conquered and banished to the fringes of
an actuality
that has become transparent to itself to
the obscure boundaries of the world
which finds itself
in the sphere of spirit and is there at
peace
these ancient gods firstborn children of
the union of light with darkness
heaven earth ocean sun the earth's blind
hymphonic
fire and so on are supplanted by shapes
which only dimly recall those titans
and which are no longer creatures of
nature
but lucid ethical spirits of
self-conscious
nations
in paragraph 707 as in the previous
paragraph we see
a partial retracing of the steps in
natural religion but now we're going
beyond it we're going to
exceed that and to bring up
incommensurability again which is not
referenced in this paragraph but wasn't
the last one we're launching into
something that doesn't
map onto the previous developments the
previous
dialectical chain that we saw in that
earlier
subsection right so hegel begins by
talking about
the black stone and he's not going to go
very far into this the
so the indwelling god is the black stone
drawn forth so it's no longer just
inhabiting that it's not a crystalline
structure it's not a
you know sort of absurd
or uh contentless thing that we're just
confronted with instead we've got the
animal form right he says
it's drawn forth from its animal
covering pervaded with the light
of consciousness and and we saw that in
the previous natural religion section
after the crystalline structure after
the discussion of of plant we have
discussion of animals and
animals can be sort of like totems
there's also
as we saw at the very end of the
discussion of the
um the worker there's this blending of
animal and human
forms a lot of people see that as a
reference to
egyptian depictions of the gods and he
says the human form
strips off the animal shape with which
it was blended so this animality this
fusion
of animal and human forms that is going
to be left
behind instead the animal can be turned
into a mere
symbol so perhaps animals can accompany
the gods they can be
identified as important to this
particular god as the the peacock was to
hera
for example uh there's always going to
be a narrative there
or you know maybe the eagle to zeus or
you know pick whatever sea animal you
want to
to poseidon or neptune and we could go
on and on
but there's also um you know plants that
are important to particular deities
we we might also think about you know
the lion skin
associated with with hercules these are
mere symbols they don't convey
the fullness of of what the god
is he says the animal is for the god
merely in
accidental guise it steps alongside its
true shape
and no longer has any worth on its own
account
so the animal no longer has any worth on
its own account it is reduced to
signifying something else
and is sunk to the level of a mere
symbol
symbols nothing wrong with them it's
just that
they don't convey the concept they don't
convey
what is really there they gesture at it
they hint at it
right so hegel is taking a position on
religion then a lot of other people
who are much more enamored of symbols
probably are not going to go down that
route
you know that's just the way it is you
kind of
pay your money and take your chances as
a friend of mine used to say all the
time
so he goes on and he says the essential
being of the god
is the unity of the universal
existence of nature right so that's one
side the universal existence
design of of nature
and of self-conscious spirit which in
its actuality confronts
the former confronts this universal
existence of nature so
already in here in the hegelian dynamic
we have nature versus
culture emerging out of nature but
but transcending it being
incommensurable with it to bring up that
term
one more time right so
how is this going to play itself out
well this is where we get to
another possibility
the titanic gods the gods of
a past who were
worshiped feared talked about
but who couldn't provide really what a
nation required so he says
here we go the form of the gods has
therefore its nature element within it
as a transcended moment that is the
titanic odds the nature element
is present within those and by the time
that we actually get
say written testimony about this or
some sort of self-conscious
understanding these gods are already
in the past deities whatever you want to
call them spirits
so he goes on and he says the chaotic
being
and confused strife of the freely
existing
elements he doesn't mean elements in a
chemical sense right
he does mean elements in the sense of
the things that things
um you know the basic stuff of the the
universe of
nature they war against each other they
don't
fit into a common schema they
jockey for position and if we think
about what are the the titans right so
we have this chaotic confused strife
an unethical realm on zlika right it's
not constrained by
ethics in the sort of full-blown sense
that we have today where we
might teach it in classes and talk about
rules or anything like that it's not
even
uh really in in the the classic senses
it like
there's no customs there's no mo
modus operandi right there's no
agreed-upon things going on
the titans fight against each other you
know
except for maybe like prometheus who
knows to get the hell out of the way
most of the titans are these
barbaric crazy beings you know
and we start out with as he mentions
right what are these these ancient gods
firstborn children of the union of light
with darkness
heaven earth ocean
sun the earth's blind tymphonic fire
right what is that referring to think
about the volcanic
activity and earthquakes and things like
that right
all of these features of the natural
environment that are not
just plant animal crystalline structures
but all the
other things the crazy winds that blow
mountain tops anything that is really
remarkable and powerful could be
a titan in that sense and there is no
there's no ethical realm
here in a certain sense when we talk
about something as being titanic
we mean it's in a certain way not just
non-human
but anti-human human beings have to
exist
in relation to it and that thing it
might care about humans maybe it'll eat
them maybe it'll crush them maybe it'll
reward them who knows what it's going to
do it's it's irrational
so we've got these titanic ads right and
he says that this unethical realm of the
titans
is what conquered and banished to the
fringes
to the fringes to the the back story
and the back waters of an actuality that
has become transparent to itself
what is this actuality that of in in
greek terms
the olympian gods zeus and hera
you know the the big six to start with
who escaped
uh their titanic father uh by
means of the help of their titanic
mother kronos was devouring all of his
children
right and so he ate up the the the three
boys and the three girls he didn't
actually eat up
uh zeus who one of the boys because uh
he ate a stone in its place right and
then zeus is brought up and they get him
to throw up all these
these gods and you get you know hera
demeter
hestia right and then you get the three
boys
hades poseidon zeus and they fight a
battle they fight a war
against the titans and they banish them
and the titans aren't just kronos
who by the way you know did a terrible
thing to his dad right
uh uranus it's also the hundred-handed
ones and the cyclopsies and
all these sorts of things right
including typhoon
so what we have is a replacement is this
actuality transparent to itself the six
olympian gods
and then their children or you know even
demigod well i mean
heracles okay is really technically a
demigod
who becomes a god at least in some of
the ways in which things are framed but
apollo and artemis and hermes and
you know all have you know hephaestus
aries
aphrodite right all of them become part
of this
like he says actuality transparent to
itself
the greeks know where these gods stand
in relation to each other because these
gods
have relations to each other that are
charted out
and worshiped in many different places
so he goes on and he says
the chaotic being and confused strife is
conquered and banished right
uh to the obscure boundaries of the
world which finds itself in the sphere
of spirit and is there
at peace these ancient gods are
supplanted by
shapes which only dimly recall these
titans
and here's the key thing they are no
longer
creatures of nature but lucid
clara ethical spirits of
self-consciousness
nations filker now notice that he
doesn't say of
a nation but nations greek
city-states that are going to war
against each other and perhaps even
we might even think of them because the
greeks thought of it this way
as uh pertaining to non-greek but close
to greek people like say the trojans
right or peoples in in other places
as well so we have a
of the understanding of the
deities the gods going on and this is
what he calls
nature transfigured by thought for
clerta
clarified made into something
new united with
self-conscious life so we have an
advance
in the understanding of the divine and
thereby on the part of the humanity the
self-conscious
human beings part of an ethical
community
part of a people or nation
part of a religious community that cults
a transformation of them in relation to
whatever it is that they're taking as
divine
you